es ist eine existenzfrage
und da muss es eigentlich egal sein ob
cdu spd oder grünen als unternehmer ist
es schwierig sich viele klima partei zu
entscheiden weil sie dich einschränkt
warum soll man denn mit noch weniger
geld in der tasche leben um sich ein
elektroauto zu können wenn wir den
klimawandel nicht aufhalten
es geht ja nicht nur uns selbst
[Musik]
lychen in brandenburg kurz nach 5 für
yvonne davis und ihren sohn casper
beginnt jeder tag so früh am morgen
ich bin morgen also ich bin
grundsätzlich versuche ich jeden morgen
kann man ja mal mit sich zu kämpfen hat
dass man auch hier um die uhrzeit
kaspar besucht die berufsschule in
prenzlau die ist 60 kilometer weit
entfernt eine direkte busverbindung gibt
es nicht zu dieser uhrzeit also fährt
seine mutter in jeden tag zur
haltestelle mit dem auto
das ist natürlich ein so ein innerer
konflikt dass du sagst okay wir leben
hier auf dem land wir wollen nachhaltig
wie wir hier bauen unsere tomaten selber
an zum beispiel ja und versuchen so viel
biss selbst zu machen müssen aber auch
selbst auto fahren ja das passt da nicht
immer zusammen aber das ist der preis
den man zahlt wenn man auf dem land lebt
dass man mobiler mit dem auto sein muss
100 kilometer weiter in berlin
verkehrsforscher andreas knie
beschäftigt sich seit jahren mit den
folgen des autoverkehrs fürs klima wenn
man im verkehr alles wirklich richtig
seriös zusammengerechnet ist der verkehr
jetzt schon für ein drittel der co2
emissionen verantwortlich und wir haben
seit 1990 gemessen bis 20 18 0
reduktionen wir müssen aber bis 20 30 -
30 prozent co2 einsparen da ist der
nahverkehr natürlich wichtig weil einen
autos im schnitt 120 125 gramm co2
emittiert deshalb würde ich es gerne
aufs auto verzichten nur das ist
schwierig sie lebt mit ihrer familie in
der uckermark einem der am dünnsten
besiedelten landstrich deutschlands die
wege sind lang so lang dass ihr zweites
kind unter der woche oft woanders
übernachtet
ich kann nicht zwei kinder morgens
so zum bahnhof oder zur bushaltestelle
bringen dass beide pünktlich ankommen
ich müsste mich teilen
um zehn nach sechs ist kaspar an der
bushaltestelle angekommen die meisten
busse in der uckermark fahren ihre
festen routen zu festen zeiten dass
viele umsteigen nervt ihn
dann wird das meine mutter erfährt und
ich dadurch ein bisschen länger schlafen
kann die anderen stehen jetzt mal hart
34 oder so auf und war so was soll man
schülern zu 34 aufzustehen und dann noch
erste stunde mathe am besten er wünscht
sich dass die busse öfter fahren auch
abends und am wochenende idee mit bussen
oder auch mit bahnen die wenig
besiedelten flächen deutschland zu
erschließen ist keine gute idee werden
auch das was die grünen wollen also der
bus fährt dann nicht mehr zweimal am tag
sondern erfährt sechsmal am tag bleibt
dasselbe problem der bus fährt immer
dann wenn ich nicht will und er fährt
dorthin wo ich auch nicht hin will das
heißt ich muss von a nach b kommen und
das wird der bus nicht mehr tun die
zukunft seien flexible emissionsfreie
busse so klima expertin claudia kemfert
wichtig ist aber dass man die
digitalisierung gestärkt bei die busse
sollten on demand kommen also es muss um
meppen
mobilitätsdienstleistungen gehen spricht
man bucht einen bus on demand und in der
zukunft das sogar auch noch selber
fahren so dass wir hier auch eine
flächendeckende ein flächendeckendes
angebot haben werden für yvonne davis
würde das bedeuten sie könnte öfter auf
ihr auto verzichten wenigstens zur
arbeit muss sie nicht pendeln zusammen
mit ihrem mann betreibt sie im home
office einen online handel für
gartengeräte
weniger auto fahren finden sie als
selbstständige nicht nur bequemer s
produziere auch weniger co2
ich wäre zwar grün in der hoffnung dass
die einen schritt weiter nach vorn gehen
aber ich traue es ihnen nicht zu dass
sie es schaffen um diese klima krise
abzuwenden müssen die radikalere
schritte gehen ja die sind unbequem auch
für uns als unternehmer
ist es schwierig sich viele klima partei
zu entscheiden die die möglicherweise
persönlich auch nicht mit weil sie dich
einschränkt in deine mobilität zum
beispiel in deinem heizverhalten zu
hause und am einkaufsverhalten aber was
habe ich davon wenn ich jetzt ein
bisschen mehr geld verdienen aber
letztendlich keine lebenswerte umwelt
habe
alternativen zum auto hat sie mit ihrer
familie und bekannten ausprobiert und
verworfen
[Musik]
das problem
dass das empfand ich als logistisch noch
aufwändiger als wenn ich mir meine
lösung kreiere auf die kann ich mich
dann auch verlassen in der region wurde
nach der wende das bahnnetz ausgedünnt
mit dem öffentlichen nahverkehr kommt
yvonne davis tochter nicht bis nach
hause
deshalb holt die mutter sie selbst am
bahnhof ab eine alternative zum
elterntaxi könnte die mit ferres' bank
sein da können sich dahin setzen und
warten dass jemand vorbei fährt der
sieht das dann ein faktor ist sehen wenn
du dann so um 17 uhr ab 10 uhr in zug
nimmt also eine gute chance dass sich
jemand wirklich
mitnimmt nach lychen und dann kennst du
meistens auch schon jemanden beim
aussteigen und dann dafür das
funktioniert ganz gut ja aber für meine
jüngere tochter kommt das noch nicht in
frage die hole ich doch dann lieber
selber ab oder aber
sie würde es machen
emissionsfreie autos und ein moderner
nahverkehr die politik müsse das endlich
konsequent angehen fordern experten
in der vergangenheit hat man politisch
zu wenig gemacht er gerade im bereich
der verkehrswende die
emissionsgrenzwerte waren zu niedrig man
hat es auch weniger auf den öpnv auf die
busse konzentriert und das ändert sich
jetzt eher schrittweise
bei dem tempo sei es noch ein weiter weg
zur erreichung der co2 ziele die
verkehrswende vollziehe sich insgesamt
zu zögerlich gerade im öffentlichen
nahverkehr so der verkehrsforscher
shuttle x den rufbus das ist aber keine
systemveränderung das was wir fordern
ist einfach vom kunden aus denken und
sagen ich will jetzt egal wo ich bin in
deutschland von a nach b ich will das
nicht sofort ich habe vielleicht zehn 15
minuten zeit und dann kommt tatsächlich
ein auto das kann ein ganz normales taxi
sein da ist schon vielleicht etwas drin
und können auch 23 sein das kann man
polen das kann auch alleine sein und das
ist natürlich auch mit einem anderen
preis zu versehen an manchen tagen fährt
er von davis bis zu 170 kilometer in
ihrem auto entgegen ihrer überzeugung
möglichst nachhaltig zu leben
dieses auto fahre ich ja schon 21 jahre
wir haben gemeinsam
250.000 kilometer auf dem buckel und er
hat jetzt seine schwächen und wie
mädchen und natürlich gucken ihr nach
und natürlich gucken wir nach
alternativen also das heißt
wir suchen schon nach einem modell das
ist so emissionsfrei wie möglich
funktioniert und dass auch sauber ist
doch wie sauber emissionsfreie autos
wirklich sind auch in der herstellung
darüber seien sie sich unsicher die
ökobilanz eines verbrenner fahrzeug ist
mit einem elektrischen und mit einer
batterie elektrische vergleicht ist das
batterie elektrofahrzeug immer noch
etwas besser selbst bei dem
augenblicklichen strommix den wir haben
aber da war immer mehr erneuerbare ins
netz bekommen wird es praktisch von
jedem jahr wird die ökobilanz für das e
auto besser man muss sich natürlich auch
daran denken dass es verbrenne auto
benzin und diesel braucht und das
basiert auf öl und diesel müssen wir
immer erst importieren und deshalb ist
das e auto auch politisch gesehen eine
viel bessere option als das verbrenner
familienrat am abend
wenn dann nicht darüber dass dies zu
teuer sind also warum soll man denn mit
noch weniger geld in der tasche leben
nur um sich ein elektroauto zu können
und dann umweltfreundlicher ist wenn wir
den klimawandel nicht aufhalten dann
später nicht nur uns selbst und ist eine
existenzfrage
und du musst es eigentlich egal sein ob
cdu spd oder grüne die haben die pflicht
dafür zu sorgen dass die zukünftigen
generationen mich das zahlen was wir
verbockt haben von den grünen hat sie
sich ein besseres ergebnis bei der
bundestagswahl erhofft zusammen mit
ihrem sohn verfolgt sie die nachrichten
im auto mieten spd-kanzlerkandidat schon
sieht einen klaren auftrag der wähler
für die sozialdemokraten und wir
möglichst bald mit grünen und fdp über
die bildung einer ampelkoalition reden
von davis ist skeptisch gerade in sachen
verkehrswende liegen fdp und grüne weit
auseinander und die zeit drängt
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich die parteien
die 1,5 in denen sie sich jetzt bekannt
habe will ich schaffen wollen eine
historische chance jetzt vertrauen meint
sie dem klimaschutz oberste priorität
einzuräumen
[Musik]